et nous sommes en ligne avec sergei pied
tour of bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes professeur de droit
international vous êtes à kiev
actuellement est ce que l'on peut
attendre quelque chose de ces
pourparlers
bonjour en fait personne attend beaucoup
de ces négociations ah parce que en
ukraine on a vu tout le tout les choses
qui est poutine a dit 'oui' a fait son
pire cauchemar c'est le cren
démocratique indépendant et prospère et
pour ça et il écrit l'expert seconde la
capitulation de nous mais les ukrainiens
nous sont braves on en sait la cinquième
jours qu'on a la guerre vicié d'ukraine
et je pense que nous gagnons dans tout
le tous les fronts contre la russie et
alors on expect seulement de ces
négociations que put in retraite avec sa
armée de l'ukraine que tout le
territoire de l'ukraine reste en
dépendons inclus crime est et dont basse
et que nous nous avons deux possibilités
de choisir notre futur et à leur sein je
pense en ce moment c'est inacceptable
pour poutine il comprend seulement à la
force la force d'armes et la force et
unités de l'europe et du monde libre l
or il va continuer à gré à l'agression
contre l'ukraine
2 moment de moment qu'il a décidé de
réintégrer tous le taux de l'ukraine
dans le monde russe qu'on me l'a déjà
fait avec la bureautique sergei
peytoureau vous vous trouvez à kiev 1 je
le disais quelle est la situation dans
la capitale à l'heure actuelle le couvre
feu a été levé pour la journée la vie
reprend au risque des sirènes on imagine
oui la nuitée à l'établi mon calme il y
avait des sirènes mais pas des tac
les quelques supermarchés sont réouverts
il ya des gens dans leur eut
aussi de pharmacie andreu ouvert
la situation est un peu nerveuse parce
que il y a encore beaucoup de beaucoup
de charbon russe dans le nom
vers la direction nord de kiev au
distance de 30 km alors il regroupe il
se prépare pour attaquer mais ici on se
sent ce jour là là le temps d'un très
beau et il ya de cela alors les gens
sont heureux de pouvoir sortir à leurs
yeux voire deux voisins de famille alors
ça revoir un petit peu d'espoir avec le
soleil le président hélène ce qui a
aussi appelé l'union européenne à à
l'adhésion immédiate de l'ukraine
pensent ils vraiment que cela soit
possible selon vous
je pense que c'est le bon moment pour
l'europe à montrer la solidarité avec
l'ukraine parce que nous nous nous
sommes partis de la grande famille
européen nous avons
nous avons tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour être dans le tout les salles de
réunions européennes
nous sommes prêts pour prendre là sièges
vacants du royaume uni et des troncs
partenaires européens et voisins et amis
de tous les nations européennes je pense
que ce le seul moment où l'europe doit
décider son position vers le crâne
sinon ce sera difficile pour nous de
comprendre qu'ils ou elles à unité
européenne dans ce moment où est la
solidarité on a vu dans différents
reportages de nos envoyés spéciaux que
certains ukrainien prennent les armes
d'autres fabriquent des cocktails
molotov il ya vraiment une mobilisation
générale en ukraine
oui c'est ça beaucoup de mes amis mais
aussi un élève sont dans le défense
territoriale même le femmes qui ont fils
qui est là à l'autre site et il est dans
l'erreur j'ai pour trouver de
logement il est avec le
la nourriture les nourritures alors tout
la nation en fait et unis maintenant
dans ces moments pour protéger notre
patrie contre l' agression massive de la
russie chacun comprend que c'est là
maintenant ce moment qui va définir la
future de notre pays pour ça chacun fait
ce qu'il peut dans ce situation très
grave merci beaucoup s'est agrippée tour
of d'avoir été en direct